for the nation South Africa is back in
the front pages again this week you've
just returned from a trip to Africa as
we sit right now on the close of 1985
are you optimistic or pessimistic about
the situation in South Africa huh well
I've been following it for a long time
and as a British person we were all kind
of brought up on South Africa because
one of my earliest memories of it being
expelled from the British Commonwealth
for its racial policy and I've been
saying sort of repetitively for years
that if the government doesn't change it
will be changed by force there'll be a
revolution and I suppose I've been
saying that as someone who thinks that
would be a just thing to happen and I
think that there the revolution isn't
around the corner it has now begun so to
that extent I guess I'd have to say I
was an optimist but in another way it
makes me sad but this it needn't have
come to this it needn't have got this
bad and it's going to get worse
and a lot of people good people are
going to die and that's needless so that
doesn't make me a pessimist but it it
qualifies my optimism good morning thank
you for joining us this morning our
topic South Africa our guest Christopher
Hitchens sees Washington correspondent
for the nation let's start off telling
people about your magazine before we
talk about something that's great
well the nation is the oldest weekly
magazine in the u.s. founded in 1865 by
a group of abolitionists and liberals
and we've held true to that tradition
ever since we wouldn't mind being called
the left end of the mainstream spectrum
we come out every week we have published
at 72 Fifth Avenue in New York City and
which subscriptions can be obtained
thank you very much and I'll write a
column for it from Washington but I'll
summarize take that column elsewhere and
I just took it to Southern Africa it how
many subscribers here and also it's got
a UK price on it - how many subscribers
in Great Britain good question I think
we have about 70,000 subscribers all
told I don't think very many of them are
in are in Great Britain very few of my
friends there do read it I'd love to say
we think the number of readers per copy
is very high a lot of libraries and
institutions of higher learning take us
I don't know what our true readership is
I should have I should have checked it
out probably about a quarter of a
million on on 17,000 it would be which
is far too few given the generally
conservative turn of the American press
and mass media these days about your
column first of all the reason for your
trip wanted to keep myself up to date I
have been in South Africa I've been in
Namibia and Angola I've been in some Bob
way Zimbabwe was a great passion of mine
for a long time I wanted to go this time
to Zambia to Lusaka to see the African
National Congress I succeeded in seeing
them and in seeing Bishop tutu when he
met with the African National Congress
actually in Zimbabwe I went to hurrah
rate as well it was the first time I
think that they've officially met I mean
he has contacted them before but they're
a banned organization in his country and
it was quite a delicate matter for him
to meet in public at a World Council of
Churches meeting with the leadership of
the organization that says it will take
power if necessary by force your
intention was to get into South Africa
itself well they've just put a freeze on
all press visas now I mean they they've
got a lot to hide and they hide it
rather clumsily by means of censorship
banning orders restrictions and so even
now in South Africa itself you need a
permit to go to Soweto was go to any of
the black townships unless you're a
black person in which case a not allowed
to leave the township and if you're a
black reporter they can't tell you you
can't go where you're forced to live
those kind of anomalies aside I mean
what one has in South Africa is a pretty
fully fledged totalitarian stage you
didn't even attempt to get in or you
knew right off the bat you mean a little
earlier than that okay the thing that's
interesting about this column and we
hear a lot of references to African
National Congress without many
explanations about what it is perhaps
you could tell our viewers well the ANC
as everyone calls it there's a slogan in
South Africa that says you a and see
nothing yet
was started in 1912 as a very modest
lobby for what were then called native
rights and it was something like what
the n-double-a-cp used to be here fairly
polite well-mannered middle-class fairly
Christian at any rate religious was
there many denominations in South Africa
and it kept on in that vein for several
decades legal was their legal
organization wasn't banned until the
1950s but as the white minority moved to
consolidate power
absolutely by law to say that South
Africa would be totally segregated and
that no black person would ever be
allowed to frame the decision on how he
or she would live the Congress had to
become more militant and in fact in 1961
it took the decision to set up an armed
wing called and Con Services way which
means the spear of the nation but it had
already been banned by that so it's
really a growth classic case of the
evolution of a modest lobbying pressure
group into a revolutionary organization
by force of circumstance like to read a
paragraph from this because it's
something I don't think I was aware up
to the references to apartheid before so
it's the political strength of the ANC
lies in its advocacy of a non-racial as
opposed to multiracial society apartheid
as people tend to forget does not merely
separate black from white and minutely
denominates blacks by tribe and language
at demarcates indians from cape colored
it separates chinese and muslim and even
designates japanese for commercial
purposes as honorary White's your
comments yeah it's worth remembering
that because apartheid people think of
us literally a black and white question
which in many ways it is but the the
system operates really on a basis of
divide and rule for example in Soweto
most the policemen tend to be recruited
from Zulu
rural areas so as to use black on black
but it's a different language that they
speak for example and
different background it's a rather
tragic thing to see you stole my
favorite point already O'Reilly didn't
steal it but you mentioned it that we've
show the real absurdity of racialism
that the Japanese are counted as
honorary Aryans honorary White's because
they have a good commercial relationship
with South Africa it's also important to
remember that the the ruling national
party in South Africa is the only ruling
party in the world that took the other
side in the Second World War I mean most
of its leaders were quite openly and
explicitly on the side of Hitler and
because of his racial theory it used to
be officially anti-semitic as a party
now because of its relationship with
Israel that slightly been watered down
but not by no means entirely it's very
strong streak of anti-jewish prejudice
in the in the Afrikaner leadership also
so that some for the ANC the task is
very difficult because it has to as well
as oppose white fascist ideology it has
to prevent tribalism and other kinds of
racial feeling breaking out among the
different groups of the oppressed and in
my view its greatest achievement is to
have done that on its executive in exile
in Lusaka there are Indians there are
colored people there quite a number of
whites in the leadership also by
coloured we mean those of mixed-race we
just for this purpose we borrow the
official definition and there are
different kinds of African all different
languages and tribes are represented and
they say that in in the South Africa of
the future your race should not count it
shouldn't be a social category at all in
deciding deciding your citizenship we
have a caller on the line so I don't
know if you can answer this question
quickly
but given that view of the South Africa
as the ANC would like it what happens to
the political side well the political
side is I think inevitably socialist in
that the the belief that there is no
meaningful definition of racial
definition of a person's right and
necessitates really belief in the
Equality Brotherhood if you like a man
and if you say that that socialist they
say yes it is some of them would say
they were communists also so you're many
people say that will automatically
invite the influence of Soviet Union
into well I wouldn't be a bit surprised
if that's what this questioner has in
mind ok I certainly would duck the
question let's add go to the phone so we
have about 45 minutes to take your calls
for Christopher Hitchens telephone
numbers are on the square of screen as a
question of our comment comes to mind
throughout this hour let's take our
first call from Lakewood New Jersey well
let's not malign the zulus I mean it's a
bit harsh I think to compare anyone to
Curren Pendleton especially at the
season of goodwill the suitors are of
course opposed to apartheid there's no
question about that one of the founders
of the African National Congress was
Chief Albert literally who was a Zulu
leader and
was I think I'm right in saying the
first black man ever to win the Nobel
Prize in 1955 there are many Zulus who
support the ANC there is an organization
led by chief gut Shabbes
bootie lazy excuse me I'll say that
again chief got shot bottlers it's
called Encarta it's a Zulu organization
and and political party and it's
tribally based and tribally organized it
is of course not in favor of white
minority rule but it is hostile to the
ANC and it's non racial policy and as a
result it is an organization with which
the South African government can do
business in pursuit of a divide and rule
policy but you shouldn't mistake Zulus
for uncle's homes and I think it would
be it would be an accurate as well as
unfair say that go out to californee for
next call where is your a town in a
comment regarding your gift first of all
to the fact that he would like to be
referred to as as left let me just say
this man is not just left he is a pro
communist mindset the South Africa the
you know the Communists are writing an
issue taking a worthwhile issue you know
anti apartheid is certainly worth well
thing to be involved in but these people
are doing just what you know the ANC is
there's no doubt that their communist
infiltrators they ply the Communist flag
it's talks we've seen that with Bishop
tutu standing there with the flag flying
behind them the race
Clinton fist and also the the apartheid
movement you know it's wrong and these
these people are writing it but they're
going to do just what they didn't need
the okay and they're you know was just
announced today that they're moving
populations maybe Ethiopia not not
because of drought but because to
relocate that for
or control politically now the thing I'd
like to say is some months ago I watched
your program with Jerry Falwell when he
came back to South Africa and the course
of watching that program after his
remarks a mr. Lowry is very except
Minister with fancy you know really far
out dressed peers and he he did the big
lie and he said that after an integer
Ebola thought he said and I'm not a pro
Jerry power person I was curious and I
watched this he said that the Jerry
Falwell didn't even visit with the
people that he flew around in
helicopters that he spoke from the other
happened how could he ever really
communicate and find out what's
happening in South Africa is black is
being said against black there are
people who are in leadership positions
that are positive and pro-america that
are you know this man would like to call
Uncle Tom's but they are not they are
people who are set and are working
toward a democratic solution of these
others these radicals won't let them
they're doing they're killing them just
like they did in if the communist method
they did it in South Vietnam they've
done it all over the world how about
that question for a second I'm asking
you is how come you didn't expose
flowery about the big lie how come the
press to sat and gobbled him up and
applauded it they sneered their
questions for Falwell were pointed
slanted and their questions to the Lowry
were just applauded whose questions you
as the press as c-span didn't catch that
didn't investigate it didn't reveal it
didn't bring out the big lie and why
they were playing this down as Wi-Fi
well basically it's been silenced and
okay why didn't you folks do that
alright and thank you for the comments
see c-span is a public affairs network
doesn't do any investigative reporting
so that's the short answer but I'd like
to get your comments to them any
observations yeah I don't I didn't mind
pointed all snotty questions either and
I don't feel that they're illegitimate
and I don't mind even the one you asked
me which I'll come to right away the
South African Communist Party
is now and was for a very long time has
been for a long time the only political
party in South Africa that doesn't
discriminate on grounds of race in its
membership this has earned it a position
of respect and admiration among a lot of
black people as you'd expect I think
it's to the credit of the Communist
Party I'm afraid I can't think of any
other way of putting it that that's
always been their view it's the only
thing that is to their credit in every
other respect politically speaking
they're an unusually conformist Moscow
line group but some of their people in
particular some of their lawyers have
acted it in my opinion heroically in the
past now what makes me so confident
about what I say about the ANC and what
makes me so sure that Jerry Falwell is
yet again either being sold a bill of
goods or selling one or both is this
there is no survey of African opinion in
South Africa that does not consistently
reveal whatever the question is and
however it's put that the popular leader
is Nelson Mandela and Nelson Mandela is
the honorary president of the African
National Congress if I'm wrong about
that I could it can be demonstrated very
easily the following method and Nelson
Mandela can be freed from prison and
invited to contest a democratic election
I would abide by that verdict and so
would he it's a very simple challenge to
make I made it on the television the
other day with mr. William Keyes the
black PR man who the South African
government is hired in this town for I
think it's 350 grand which I don't think
he's worth his response was to me was to
say that that would be like calling for
the release of Charles Manson if you'll
buy that you'll buy Jerry Falwell I will
simply repeat that Iowa I will abide by
the result of a democratic election I
think Nelson Mandela would win it but if
you want to prove me wrong I'd have to
address your question to South African
government Sheboygan Wisconsin good
morning hi I have about four questions
I'd like to ask your guest speaker on
South Africa okay all right begin happy
holidays thank you the same to you sir
look I don't know if he will be able to
answer them but here goes anyway it
seems that tribalism has always been a
fierce force in all of Africa shows a
little sign of ever stopping what makes
you think that this fierce tribalism
would stop in South Africa if the blacks
were to get any kind of power second
point all the boycotts have been list
lifted against Russia and for anyone to
tell me that South Africa is the worst
political pull force in the world and
leave out the genocide that goes on in
Cambodia the hostilities that Russia is
putting against Afghanistan is very
naive it seems that we have selective
indignation against the South Africans
ok next point it seems that little is
said it seems that the news media is
saying that the South African Armed
Forces is insignificant they have yet
begun to flex their muscles from what I
understand they have a large standing
army very powerful Air Force and an
effective Navy what would be the role of
this force if the whites felt that their
backs were against the wall ok the last
point is there are still in the news
media very little coverage about
atrocities and the rest of black Africa
very little coverage is given how blacks
leave other parts of Africa and go into
South Africa don't get me wrong the
conditions aren't that great but they
appear to be better than in their own
land in some of the border areas between
South Africa and the rest of black
Africa there's barbed wire people are
shot their bodies are left to rot these
are by black governments that let this
be I hope you'll be able to answer my
questions I've called it some other
times
given this kind of questions and they
seem to be always looked over okay thank
you very much - take care bye-bye well
let me try not to disappoint you on no
your first question on tribalism yes
it's the curse of Africa and every
African nationalist knows it and it's
the reason for the existence of the OAU
which is in itself the organization of
African Unity one of the most
disappointing organizations in the
modern world is that at least they
recognize that that is the problem it's
it's a double problem because the
borders of Africa that that denominated
Nations and differentiate States were
not drawn by Africans they were drawn by
colonial powers a very large number them
were drawn by my fellow countrymen the
British and don't follow or conform to
tribal or other differences at all
they're drawn for the convenience of
outsiders and Africa is still saddled
with that what I was saying about the
ANC is that it realizes that this is
this is the main problem and says that
to join the organization you give up
your claim as a tribal or otherwise
racially defined person you have to try
and decolonize as it were your mind and
all I can all I can say for them is that
they have made that leap of recognition
and they are the only organization in
the country that does give the promise
overcoming tribal feeling but it would
be a fool or an optimist or utopian who
didn't recognize the the depth of it I
mean for example in Zimbabwe where all
Africans were agreed that white colonial
rule should cease that was about all
they did agree about and there is still
a very deep going a political quarrel
between the matter Billy and the Mashona
in the country as we speak whatever the
answer to that is though it is not white
colonial rule I think we have to move
beyond that stage I hope you don't think
I've dodged your question then on
tribalism on the double standard and the
boycott thing yes and no I didn't say
anything about Cambodia or Afghanistan
because I was asked about South Africa
but I would have done if I had been
asked the difference I think
inescapable difference is this the
Soviet economy is not dependent on
Western capitalist corporations the
South African economy to a very large
extent is that's to say we are in the
West responsible for South Africa in not
just in the moral sense but in the
practical sense money is made by
American and British corporations
principally but also by French ones and
West German ones from that economy its
labor practices and its system of double
oppression that's to say people are
pressed both as workers and as people of
a different color is in our camp
thus the call for sanctions and boycotts
is not just a matter of a gesture it's a
matter of accepting and recognizing the
responsibility that I think
distinguishes it from say the Polish
economy though though if you were to say
to me that the Polish economy is largely
underwritten by Western banks you'd be
right and I'd be in favor of taking the
point in the same way I'm not for a
double standard on the army and the
sorry we've got a caller that's been
waiting a bit and rather than long
distance why don't I take that call
we'll go back to the last two I just the
the I'm anxious was the questioner said
he had his question slowed off before
I'm keen to take them on the chin okay
we will get back to them okay sure
Portsmouth Virginia go ahead please good
morning morning I like to comment and
I'd like to make an invitation to you
first of all president of glory
Enterprise and Educational Foundation
13:17 Brambleton Avenue 2/3 504 and I
know you're smiling but the reason I
give you that christopher's because I'm
hoping that you would have them than I
did to come to Virginia I think that the
citizens of Virginia need people like
you to address them their life
understanding of world of global problem
what you speak as we have to go beyond
organism
as I was saying it will be on back
premising I think one of the things that
we need to consider is that there is a
little babies being affected by the
oppression around the country and I
heard a little mission about back to
these innocent little children caught up
between the struts by comet here first
and second mr. [ __ ] this do you view the
world Isis as our Aegis gross human
rights violations is my first question
and my second question Christopher if
would you say that these men yield to
God our world leaders do they even
conceive in their comments at all that
little children of a deprived Fredo okay
thank you for the call it's not
obviously just at Christmastime that one
thinks of what a reproach it is that any
child should have to suffer for these
stupidities and crimes of of people you
know better are people like ourselves
but I suppose that makes it a more
appropriate time for some people anyway
even people like myself one aren't lucky
enough to have a belief in God sustain
them aren't immune from the the
Christmas sentiment that's I suppose why
South Africa moves people so much
because though we know that the human
race has all kinds of inherent
difficulties and possibilities that it
will it's by nature unhappy there are
some things we can see that are done
that are just unnecessary that we know
we can kill and that are that are
needless and one of these is is racial
prejudice any any thinking person can
see through it and outgrow it and to see
it in practice is is an outrage and to
feel that one's own government or one's
own system is in any way condoning or
supporting it is a terrible reproach
also so I hope that's I hope
it's a sort of answer to your question
we'll take a call from Sant Antoni and
then we'll get back to those two
questions les our producer to hold off
with calls for just a second so we can
get those two responses san antonio good
morning morning I think you make a good
point on the multilateral nature of the
problem in South Africa and I'm glad to
hear that the African National Congress
also recognizes it I think it's easier
to unite against something like the
whites then I think you would see the
divisions among the African National
Congress be much more pronounced if they
came into power and but the government
and media in the United States seem to
make this a black versus white questions
and ignoring in other countries
oftentimes black on black and
intertribal between black problems I
think the fear of some of us there are a
little more to the right of yourself is
that will exchange in South Africa a
racial elites for a communist elite I
have two questions for you though you
seem to think that the revolution is
underway do you think the president
government and the moderates that are in
that government are finished and the
second question you see the ANC if they
were successful in the coming in power
at being pro West or pro-soviet thank
you okay this is part of the answer to
the question of a for last as well I
don't believe the story about the the
moderates in the Botha government I just
don't know who they are
they've never have successfully been
identified and certainly there's no
action by which we could recognize them
as moderate as I say the the ideology of
the National Party the ruling party is
not just a racial one it's it's a
fascistic one it's it's one that grew
out of admiration for the Third Reich
and the losing side in the last war and
that that's an important I think thing
to bear in mind if they were ever going
to be moderate they've had ample chances
to prove it I mean even at the time of
the Sharpeville massacre when there was
such an outcry in 1961 around the time
the ANC was banned the government was
saying are but you wait there's a reform
program on the way you know what what is
all this international outcry about
we're changing for the better
quite to the contrary it changed for the
worse and continue to do so I think that
down the road and here's part of the
answer to the South African army
question I was asked earlier there's the
real chance for a military coup in the
country certainly at the moment the army
under general Magnus Milan effectively
has a great share of state power and for
instance by the use of it keeps Namibia
Southwest Africa an independent country
under complete occupation and subjection
I also think and it's a it's a terrible
prospect but I think a real one and one
that hasn't yet been written about
there's a serious problem of death
squads in South Africa a large number of
people opponents black and white of the
regime have been disappearing or being
mysteriously murdered
I think there's almost no doubt as to
who's behind it and very little doubt
that it will increase I even wonder if
the allegedly anti white bomb
in Durban yesterday was planted by
anyone who's really opposed to the
regime I'm afraid that the ideology and
the entrenched racism of the National
Party is likely only to get worse as it
approaches it's it's death agony will go
back then
since you've answered three out of four
the fourth one is on the atrocities in
the rest of Africa yeah well yes I mean
I I mean I'll give people the benefit of
the doubt on that I mean just to say
well the rest of Africa it's all black I
mean as if you know they all look alike
to you which is the unconscious
assumption of a lot of these questions I
find objectionable but let's admit that
whatever the problem in the Congo is for
example or Uganda it isn't white
minority rule what I think is
distinctive about South Africa and this
is very well put it by Joseph Louella
felt in the New York Times in his really
excellent book on the subject it's
called movie or shadow it's published by
New York Times books I really recommend
it it's the best anatomy of the topic
that I've yet read is this if you are
poor in South Africa which is a very
rich country it is because you're black
it's it is a matter of
date policy if your maltreated and if
you're exploited and if you're told
where you can and can't live and if
you're told that you can't vote all the
rest of it it's deliberate it's a it's a
systematic policy you're intended to be
like that now that isn't true in the
same way of an unfortunate in the middle
of the you can you got a civil war for
example it isn't it isn't such a
deliberate infliction on him even if his
condition as it would be in some cases
is a worse one objectively I hope I hope
that point has come across I I think
it's one that explains what some people
always want to ask which is why does one
go on about South Africa so much that's
why did I leave anything out why do
people go and work there when they're
black because South Africa dominates the
regional economy it is it is the it
holds a commanding position in in
minerals and industry in capital if you
live in Mozambique for example over the
border you have two options you can
either cross the border and work as
virtually a slave as an indentured labor
with no rights whatever even fewer
rights than a black South Africa or you
can have no work at all I don't really
think therefore a person who resolves
that problem by crossing the border as
an indentured labour is paying any
compliment to the South African system
newspapers this morning have many
editorials on South Africa from the
Washington Times to the Washington Post
we take our next call from Grand Rapids
to show you the Tony of--the cartoon in
the Philadelphia Enquirer on South
Africa good morning caller you're on the
air good morning morning I wanted to ask
mr. Hitchens about South Africa and why
everyone seems to be so against a
homeland concept maybe the way it's
implemented right now it is wrong and
I'm not certainly in favor of apartheid
but it doesn't seem to me after living
in the country for a few months that
there's actually going to be a
power-sharing it that that it's possible
it's workable down there
it seemed like a division of the country
and separate rule is just about the only
way that there's going to be a peace and
peaceful solution thank you
well some people have said that the the
end result of all this will be a
repartition of the country with in
effect the whites building themselves a
Baptist on and not trying to rule
everybody else as well as themselves I
think myself that's unlikely because the
repartition of the country would mean
them giving up the areas that are rich
in gold and uranium and the other and
diamonds and the other reasons that
they're there in the first place but
your question is good I mean the they're
only there are only two possible
outcomes one is a generalized collapse
of the country in which every racial
tribal international group tries to grab
something for itself including the white
tribe and the other is the the solution
of the anc which is a non-racial
republic which reminds me i do have a
question unanswered which is what form
of government whether pro eastern or pro
west and i think that would take i think
the answer to that question lies very
much with the United States
if the United States has it in its power
to resolve that question if it persists
in the present policy of actually I
think they're too embarrassed to
continue calling it constructive
engagement but anyway of effective
collusion and collaboration with South
African regime then the successor regime
will not be friendly to the United
States Norfolk Virginia good morning
being the economic Frank Oh nation is so
and I was just wondering about the newly
formed Congress itself in trade union
leader mr. Elijah
sorry I don't he is uh challenged ever
met he's giving him like six month
mister both yes and I was wondering if
he was like I know this Union right now
joining a string
we have a slightly vague connection I'm
afraid I'm not hearing everything you
say caller would you start that sentence
over again we just lost that one start
your last sentence over again okay do
you do you see a strike by this Union as
they're barely crippling the nation and
what do you see the United States doing
okay thank you okay
well yeah as I said earlier I mean the
the South African system there it is
based on a racial demarcation is also a
system of exploitation I mean if it even
if it was everyone there was the same
color it would still be an outrageous
system of exploitation and the emergence
of the Congress of South African trade
unions is one of the most powerful signs
of that discontent in the last several
years for the very reason you mentioned
which is the extreme vulnerability of an
economy that's so heavily based on
foreign investment already you see
foreign investors are beginning to doubt
whether they spent their money wisely
and are reluctant to invest any more
the around the national currency almost
went through the floor the other day
because of foreign confidence and and
its erosion so I think that a mass
workers movement is a very likely means
for the for the Advancement of the of
the black and Democratic cause if you've
just joined us recently we're talking
with Christopher Hitchens this morning
he is the Washington correspondent for
this publication in the nation he has
been with the organization's since 1978
also Washington correspondent for The
Spectator based in London and writes a
column on the American scene for London
Times Literary Supplement your prior
assignments were for another of the new
statements and author of a book called
Cyprus you're very well in fluent we've
got about 20 minutes left with mr.
Hitchens let's go next to Houma
Louisiana good morning I saw you the
television was an interview that you did
with that uh South African black PR man
and I found that a very interesting
interview because of the fact that
a black man was supporting the basic
apartheid government
what was it televised alright if you
don't mind me saying it was on the cable
news network okay on crossfire and the
thing that was I found very amazing is
that Robert will be one of the course
the correspondents that was in the
interview really like Apple it was I
forget some the words that he used you
feel like that you were backing a
communist type government of South
Africa and things like that but just a
few short questions number one does the
white government in South Africa have
enough artillery to to keep the black
population from just flat-out over
Sorrento if you came down to that number
do what do you think will be I know
we've kind of dearly done it around on
this the whole program but what do you
think will be the final outcome of South
Africa and that's all that's all like
that okay thank you yeah um actually I
was
I still realize I've I've left a
question to angling which you've
reminded me of about the Armed Forces
South Africa has tremendously
sophisticated Western provided armaments
it ranks really almost as a NATO member
with some of its alliances and with the
sort of equipment to which it has access
either from the West or from Israel it
also has nuclear weapons which it
acquired from the Israelis in the French
or the technology for what should
acquired from the Israelis in the French
but none of this is going to do it any
good I mean they can invade if they do
invade Angola they've made incursions
into Mozambique in Zimbabwe they occupy
the whole of South West Africa Namibia
and they could certainly beat any army
that the rest of Africa combined could
put in the field but it's not going to
help them against their own people I I
think there are fanatics in the
government who would go as far as say
Somoza did in his dying days and
literally bombed their own cities we're
not going to nuclear bomb their own
cities the nukes are no good to them
they are in effect powerless if the
black majority simply decides to fold
its arms and withdraw cooperation which
i think is an increasingly likely
because the system is based on the
exploitation of cheap labor the white
song kind of starts going down the mines
and doing all the all the dirty work
they they're gonna collapse if that
happens they will of course go to great
lengths to ensure that it doesn't to try
and decapitate the political leadership
to keep some of the statue of Nelson
Mandela in prison for a quarter of a
century and so forth but see how little
good it's done there many people who
weren't born when Nelson Mandela went
into prison and he hasn't been quoted in
the South African newspaper since then
it's illegal to quote if it's illegal to
print his picture or his name and
everyone in South Africa knows who he is
and he's a hero to people who weren't
born when he went inside in the end the
whole attempt to keep this going by
force is futile it may end in blood and
fire or it could end quickly and cleanly
and the reason why I go on about this is
that the West could make a difference
that economy is plugged into ours we
could decoupled really bring pressure to
bear that what the administration fails
to see is that doing nothing is a policy
doing nothing is a decision and looks to
those on the bottom like a decision to
stay with us on the top and there's no
escaping a decision of that clarity in
my view let me share another auditor
before we go to our next call this is
this morning's Washington Times this is
Mandela show they write to every
incident such as this weekend's
manhandling of mrs. Mandela no matter
how provocative chips away at the idea
of ending apartheid gradually State
President PW Botha must act promptly
and yes radically to consign that
monstrous system to the past
that's the Washington Times that's let's
go next to Rock Hill South Carolina good
morning caller go ahead what's your
question what is your question sir
okay thank you for the call
I agree I mean I I don't think that
needs I think that was its own comment
can you last night on National Public
Radio commentators were referring to
this scenario between mrs. Mandela and
mr. Boutros government as a chess game
could you comment on what what is
happening or at least your overview of
it no chess is much more fluent and
fluid and subtle game than than they
know how to play I mean that was just
another stupid manifestation of the
apartheid regime people say why do they
act so dumb Lee you know why do they get
themselves in positions like that it's
the nature of the beast I'm afraid if
you if you say first to mrs. Mandela
because you're black you have to live in
Soweto she can't choose which part of
Johannesburg she lives in then they say
well you're free but you can't go home
to the place we otherwise say you have
to go to what you've done is simply
expose the ironies if you like the
contradictions the stupidities of your
own system none of the none of the
apparent blunders of this regime
analyzed in the West as blunders are
blunders at all they are they are
apartheid at work New York City good
morning morning the South African
government has been reported saying that
they would release Nelson Mandela if he
renounced violence I'd like your comment
on that and also don't you feel that in
order to stave off a resurrection if you
will from the right from the Army that
you mentioned before it's necessary to
have not moderate because the time has
come for terms like that to be
eliminated but someone who represents
very very much the establishment to take
the steps to move South Africa in the
direction that perhaps we might consider
more acceptable for their general
populace okay the renunciation of
violence is just a trick what they say
is we'll release her if you surrender
Nelson Mandela says don't be ridiculous
he countered by saying he would he would
stay
prison if the South African government
itself renounce to Ireland I mean that's
you know that's simply propaganda the
time for it is a long time ago if they
wanted the ANC to renounce violence they
could have dealt with it when it
renounced violence itself I mean the ANC
was a pacifist organisation until very
late in the day Chief Albert was truly
sir its ditz chairman I think certainly
was a pacifist and I think I said
earlier it was only 961 the decision was
taken to move to resistance Mandela will
would rather stay in prison would rather
die than tell his people to surrender
and that's a measure of his stature in
my view I don't think anyone really fell
for Berta's kontrick there
as for the moderates where you said
yourself it's become an absurd so I
don't know where you're going to find
the person of goodwill I'm afraid that
the some that seems to be something in
the nature of the ideology of the
National Party that prevents it from
evolving moderates I would think that
the element of its ideology that
prevents it from evolving moderates is
to say that moderation is the agency of
the devil and that their rule is
biblically ordained that doesn't kind of
conduce to moderation if you're watching
this program live on this December 24th
we invite you to stay tuned in about 10
minutes we'll be having our open phone
session and the topic this morning is
the man of the year
next week Time magazine will be coming
out with its annual issue naming the
event or person who for good or ill has
changed the world this year and we'd
like to hear your nominations on whom
you think would best be awarded the man
of the year this year let's go for
Christopher Hitchens Way Out West at
Chula Vista California good morning
you're on the air caller you're on the
air sir dr. your yes oh it's right there
go ahead you know you already come
across a couple of signs about South
Africa right yeah and you know I do
agree with some of their philosophies
there are certain things that I don't
agree with yours huh okay why don't you
name one and we'll respond to it okay
one of them is why did the American or
how come to Tsavo the South African
government a red that lady in that
government right
what do you disagree with sir why is it
I want to know why they arrested her
okay
I think we did respond well yes but I I
mean I could just say quickly because
she is while her husband Nelson Mandela
remains in prison
where he's been for 21 years as the
spokesman of the black majority she very
courageously acts as his spokesman and
as she believes he would wish her to act
while his part excuse me while he's
powerless for this she has incurred the
hatred and the repression of the South
African government and has for the last
decade at least been in in restriction
as they call it which means that she's
being confined to her home the column
that you've written in the nation this
week is called Minority Report have you
been filing some columns from Africa as
we travel that was the second of two
that I did from from southern Africa
yeah it's always called Minority Report
that's it's its name
how many do you anticipate writing on
this topic um well it looks like it's
not gonna go away as an issue it's gonna
stay in the headlines so I hope I'll be
able to keep up with it and I hope I'll
be able to return how long were you
actually there I was there three weeks
okay let's take our next call for you
from Knoxville Tennessee good morning
morning okay your question sir first of
all I'd like to say that I enjoy your
program very much thank you and secondly
I'm very much against apartheid as a
whole but I think there are several
questions that have to be answered
people think that there are going to be
two things happen first of all on the
vibes overthrow or there'll be some kind
of compromise but I think you're dealing
with this situation much like you had in
India when they first achieved their
freedom I don't believe there's any
blacks who can really rule the kind
South Africa they've been suppressed for
so long
and even if Nelson Mandela you know were
released from prison by any stretch of
imagination I don't believe he's able to
rule South Africa that does not say that
they don't deserve their freedom I
believe they do but you know the the
country is a very important economic
force in the world and it can just not
just be um thrown to the wind of
revolution thank you thank you if you
were took the executive of the African
National Congress and added up all the
university degrees and other
qualifications that they have between
them not to speak of the decades in
prison that they've amassed as well the
wastage of their time or rather in spite
of all that you'd find that it easily
easily outbid the collected expertise
and qualifications of the South African
cabinet there's no question at all that
the ANC if it's permitted to can form a
an orderly transition regime there and
could be voted into power if an election
was held if that isn't allowed to happen
it's not the ANC's fault and yes there's
a possibility if the extreme right go
down fighting that the place could go
through a Lebanese experience before it
gets to its independence but what you
can't stop is people wanting that
independence by one means or another
they've taken the decision as I put it
in my article that this is the last
unfree generation that they will survive
the regime that decision once taken is
is quite impossible to untag so it'll
come one way or another and I repeat the
Western democracies have a large role to
play in deciding whether it will come by
by democratic means or not mr. Hitchens
next calls from Anchorage good morning
good morning know the greatest show in
the world gone oh thank you sir happy
holidays stream happy holidays to you
but I wanted to this
the advocacy of disinvestment in South
Africa on the part of all sorts of
American amenities University trust
funds municipal retirement funds etc and
waivable we up in Alaska believe it or
not we have thing called our permanent
fund and have from our oil revenues
something in the order of ten billion
dollars invested in wall street and
various securities it just seems to me I
believe that there are those who are
advocating this have it backwards so to
speak I think there's a tendency upon
those who are acutely concerned about
apartheid in South Africa the advocacy
of disinvestment seems to be backwards
it's like running it's like playing
Pontius Pilate washing one's hands for
the situation for example if the state
of Alaska rather than disinvesting if we
were to go on to the stock market I
believe of the five hundred
international corporations non-american
corporations the nine largest in South
Africa and make the list seven them are
available for purchase in no case do any
of those corporations have a stock
market value of a billion dollars so our
we could effectively go in state of
Alaska's permanent funds go in and buy
operative control of the seven of the
nine largest corporations of South
Africa and that's without getting into
most of the gold mine stock and I just
wonder if Willie that wouldn't be the
way to go about it just effectively have
our pension fund by control of all the
South African corporations and then
maybe we could tell the corporation's
maybe you up to allow the families to
live with the with the workers we're
going to build housing we're going
to have equal pay and by golly if it
cost us a little bit for a while why
maybe we'll just break even instead of
making a profit and then where is the
South African government going to get
their revenues I have a suspicion some
of the people who are heavily advocating
this just don't like the profit motive
they don't like owning equity in
corporations they from other
philosophical positions they might have
a lie even nation magazine and but I
think it might be a more responsible way
to go on I think we might get more bang
for the bunk [ __ ] be acting
responsibly and putting it into
apartheid thank you very much okay we're
running out of time
sure um first very free to get a call um
all the way from Anchorage from the
great state of Alaska whose senator
honest Gruening actually used to be
editor of the nation before he took
Alaska into the Union so I always feel a
fellow feeling for anyone in Alaska and
that's certainly the most ingenious
question we've had today I think we'd
have to say it had never occurred to me
before actually to buy them out and I
really don't know whether they'd sell I
think the African National Congress
would probably say the the resources the
most of which are actually underground
in South Africa it's a tremendously
mineral rich place belong to them into
the future and they want to have a say
in whoever owned them but and I think
that would actually be their first
response but I just congratulate you for
an amazingly ingenious proposal all the
same two minutes left our last calls
from Roanoke good morning excuse me good
morning how are you today fine sir I
would like to find out so why it is
perfectly okay it's a monkey that the
American people shouldn't be able to
monkey with the government from an
external point of view with a government
that is non communist yet you as a
newspaper wish to prohibit us from
monkeying with a communist government to
turn it around to a free government no
not quite what I said earlier was this
we already are intervening in South
Africa that's to say the the flow of
capital investment and weapons into
South Africa it all comes from the West
so the the the intervention has already
been made
the point is if we can intervene one way
why can't we intervene another since
that relationship doesn't exist between
the United States government and any
communist one I don't think your analogy
holds but if it did I'd be in favor of
the same policy we're out of time for
Christopher Hitchens thank you for
joining us this morning
thanks Erin thank you for your questions
and comments on South Africa interesting
morning